wie haben sie Putin wie haben sie seine
Drohung
verstanden also zunächst einmal würde
ich sagen Herr Putin ist ein bisschen
spät mit seiner Drohung dass er
militärisch mal wieder drohen würde war
ja zu erwarten immerhin ist Finnland nun
seit einem halben Jahr
vollständiges Mitglied in der NATO
zum eigentlichen NATO Beitritt Finnlands
hat er sich eigentlich relativ bedeckt
gehalten aber nun haben sich die Dinge
ein bisschen geändert weil Finnland
natürlich logischerweise dabei ist jetzt
auch nicht nur amerikanische Präsenz
auch übungspräsenz sondern im nächsten
Schritt natürlich auch eine
natoinrastrukturelle Präsenz mit
vorzubereiten und darauf mein er wohl
reagieren zu müssen wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen Präsident Putin befindet
sich im Wahlkampf und die Aussagen die
wir Ihen gehört haben passen ganz
typisch dazu einmal mehr spielt er den
Ball quasi in die westliche Ecke und
behauptet also wir hätten wir die
westliche Welt die natomitglieder hätten
Finnland in die NATO gezerkt was
ja nun eine echte
falsche Aussage ist mhm was würden Sie
denn sagen wie ernst muss man diese
Drohung tatsächlich nehmen von
Putin also natürlich gefällt es dem
Kremmel überhaupt nicht und kann es ihm
auch nicht gefallen dass er nun mehr
fast von natoitgliedern
äh auch fin Land
ich will nicht sagen umzingelt ist aber
dass sich die Finnen eben wirklich auch
auf der Basis eines sehr transparenten
demokratischen gesellschaftlichen
Prozesses entschieden haben ihren
neutralitätsstatus hinter sich zu lassen
und angesichts eines
sebbelrassenden gewaltbereiten und
expansiven Russlands ihre
Sicherheitspartnerschaft in der NATO zu
suchen das blendet erer alles aus aber
ich
bin nicht allzu sehr besorgt ich halte
es nach wie vor überhaupt nicht in dem
Kalkül von Präsident Putin ein
natostaat militärisch also konventionell
oder gar auch nuklear anzugreifen ich
glaube nicht dass das etwas ist was er
ohnehin im Sinne hatte aber er hat
natürlich auch in der Vergangenheit sehr
stark auf hybrideemittel zurückgegriffen
und auch äh mit der jüngsten wenn Sie so
wollen gezielten Destabilisierung durch
irakische afghanische und andere
Migranten die da auf der
an der finnischen Grenze jetzt
aufgetaucht sind immer wieder ein Mittel
gefunden um sein altes äh Kalkül weiter
fortzusetzen also die Nachbarn zu
destabilisieren mhm bevor wir gleich
noch mal über diese Aktion die sie jetzt
gerade angesprochen haben sprechen er
hat ja auch in dem Zitat was wir jetzt
eingangs eingeblendet haben und gezeigt
haben gesagt man werde diesen
Militärbezirk Leningrad schaffen er hat
es aber bisher nicht viel konkreter
gemacht wie könnte dieser Militärbezirk
aussehen also es gibt
eine ganze Reihe von Informationen die
schon aus dem Sommer stammen dass der
russische Generalstab das russische
Verteidigungsministerium begonnen hat
militärdistrikte in etwas größerem
Rahmen
umzuorganisieren und die Auflösung des
eigentlich bis dahin geltenden
sogenannten westlichen militärdistrikts
der dann auch an die Grenze Russlands
hätte ist bereits im Sommer beschlossen
worden also jetzt mit einem neuen
militärdistrikt zu kommen der wie schon
sagte im Sommer beschlossen worden ist
ist nicht jetzt wirklich eine Neuigkeit
aber ich bin ziemlich zuversichtlich
dass Russland in diesem Bezirk wie
überhaupt entlang seiner westlichen
Grenze größere Truppen Umgruppierung
vornehmen wird natürlich auch
mit
unter Einbeziehung der jeweiligen
militärischen Fähigkeiten um seine
eigene Abschreckung gegenüber der NATO
zu unterstreichen das sind in erster
Linie vor allen Dingen denke ich mal
strategische Botschaften die damit
verbunden werden aber es gibt bestimmt
auch die eine oder andere Übung die die
russische Seite in diesem neuen nicht
mehr wirklich ganz neuen Leningrader
Militärbezirk Unternehmen wird Frau wir
bekommen dazu natürlich die ganze Zeit
auch schon Fragen bei YouTube eine geht
in die Richtung von Mike hätte Russland
denn überhaupt eine Chance gegen
Finnland als zweite Front und dann
ergänzend noch dazu uns genügend
Streitkräfte hierfür wenn wir eben sehen
dass viele Streitkräfte viele russische
Kräfte gerade auch im Krieg in der
Ukraine im Einsatz sind es ist eine gute
Frage die führt mich wieder zu diesen
Umstrukturierung zurück von denen ich
eben sprach auf der russischen Seite die
sind unter anderem auch vorgenommen
worden um let letztendlich Kräfte neu an
eben diese Westgrenze
zu dislozieren die während des
ukrainekrieges oder jetzt eigentlich
immer noch in großem Teil dort
eingesetzt worden sind wir wissen ja
dass Russland also fast 300.000 oder
sogar noch mehr Verwundete und getötete
Soldaten zu verzeichnen hat das heißt
also sie werden diese Kräfte neu
auffüllen müssen um letztendlich nicht
nur in der Ukraine äh weiterkämpfen zu
können und die dortigen taktisch
operativen militärischen Ziele zu
erreichen sondern auch um eben dieses
Maß an besonderer militärischer
Abschreckung zu demonstrieren das wird
den Russen sehr sehr wichtig sein aber
um auf die Frage vielleicht ein bisschen
konkreter zu antworten ähm nein ich habe
nicht den Eindruck also dass Russland
weder den politischen Willen noch also
jetzt im größeren Maße
äh die Fähigkeiten hat um eine zweite
Front zu eröffnen ähm das wird äh das
wird der Kremmel nicht tun weil er
natürlich auch weiß mit wem er sich dann
auch wirklich anlegen
würde wir haben es Eingang schon gesagt
schon der NATO Beitritt Finnlands war
Putin an Dorn im Auge das sogenannte DCA
Abkommen also Def Fans coroporation
agreement war dann jetzt offenbar ein
Schritt zu viel für Putin können Sie uns
einmal bitte erklären was bedeutet
dieses Abkommen ganz
konkret also Finnland die finnische
Regierung hat mit der amerikanischen
Regierung einen Sicherheits Abkommen
getroffen eines von ich würde mal sagen
einem ganzen Teil unterschiedlicher
Abkommen die es auch in der
Vergangenheit immer gegeben hat aber
dieses ist jetzt ein erster
unmittelbarer Folgeschritt äh des
natobeitritts Finlands weil er äh aus
finnischer Sicht amerikanischen Truppen
erlaubt äh nicht nur Übung auf
finnischem Territorium durchzuführen
sondern eben auch Stützpunkte zu nutzen
diese Stützpunkte sind da ähm ganz
konkret eben auch benannt worden und ich
sag's noch mal das ist ein wirklich
erster logischer Schritt denn natürlich
ist die Mitgliedschaft Finnlands in der
NATO jetzt kein akademisches
theoretisches Konstrukt sondern wir
werden auch in den nächsten Monaten und
in den nächsten Jahren sehen dass wir
auf dem Territorium Finnlands auch hier
und da ähm natoübung und NATO
strukturelle Formen finden werden wie
die im Einzelnen aussehen das ist ja
auch Teil der
beitrittsverhandlung gewesen zwischen
Finnland und der NATO und wird sich
jetzt im Folgenden in den folgenden
Monaten
und Jahren immer weiter konkretisieren
damit eben schlussendlich Finnland auch
wirklich
unmittelbarer Teil der
verteidigungsanstrengung und der
abschreckungsfunktion der NATO wird wenn
Sie die Abschreckung und die
verteidigungsfunktion der NATO jetzt
schon ansprechen wo sind denn aus
natoerspektive da tatsächlich auch rote
Linien wir haben ja in der Vergangenheit
z.B immer wieder Luftraumverletzungen
auch gesehen also ab wann greift Artikel
5 bzw ab wann müssten NATO Truppen
Eingreifen
ähm also es gibt ein ziemlich
klar beschriebenes Prozedere wie im
Falle einer Eskalation die NATO intern
reagiert grundsätzlich m müssen wir uns
vorstellen dass die NATO ein sehr gut
ausgeprägtes sogenanntes early warning
system hat intelligence System hat also
dass die Bewegung auf der russischen
Seite entlang der finnischen Grenze und
überhaupt
in der Ostregion und auch in der
arktischen Region sehr sehr genau
beobachtet und auswertet und diese
jeweiligen Analysen werden dann in einem
wirklich sehr ersten Schritt Miteinander
mit den Verbündeten geteilt und das
macht die
finnische Botschafterin die in der NATO
ist ist mit ihrem Team äh die perit
Asuna genauso auch sie werd über ihre
eigenen finnischen Kanäle immer wieder
die Verbündeten unterrichten und sollte
es nun zu einer ähm zu einer
Lagebeurteilung kommen die wirklich sehr
sehr besorgniserregend ist dann würde
die finnische Botschafterin in der NATO
mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwann
mal in diesem Prozess sagen ich möchte
eine Befassung nach Artikel 4 des
washington Vertrages das bedeutet also
dass hier schon eine ernsthafte
Bedrohung eines Mitgliedes artikuliert
wird und demementsprechend auch wenn Sie
so wollen die politische Temperatur ein
kleines bisschen höher gestellt wird
das ist nicht allzu oft in der
Vergangenheit passiert aber immer mal
wieder und das wäre der allererste
Schritt um überhaupt die NATO in ihrer
Gesamtheit auf dieses Problem zu
fokussieren der nächste darauffolgende
Schritt sollte sich dann eine
Lagebeurteilung ergeben die so
dramatisch ist also dass die finnische
Regierung zu dem Schluss kommt wir
fühlen uns in unserer
territorialen Integrität und
Souveränität so unmittelbar und
existentiell bedroht wir wollen den
Artikel 5
aktivieren dann würde auch das über die
finnische Botschafterin die Frau ausumna
artikuliert werden im nordatlantikrad
und dann würde eben dieser
nordatlantikrad zusammenkommen und je
jeder
einzelne Mensch der dort sitzt jeder
einzelne Botschafter jedes einzelne
Mitglied würde für sich entscheiden inwi
weit es diese Lagebeurteilung teilt und
inwi weit es bereit ist darauf zu
reagieren der Punkt den ich wirklich
hier unterstreichen möchte vielleicht
zuletzt ist es gibt keinen Automatismus
sondern es gibt wirklich eine sehr feine
sehr systematische sich dann
verstärkende Lagebeurteilung die auf der
Basis der jeweiligen intelligence also
der der geheimdienstlichen Beurteilung
aus dem Mitgliedschaft
aus der aus dem Mitgliedstaat und aus
der NATO
kommen ich habe sie jetzt ja richtig
verstanden dass sie sozusagen die akute
Gefahr einer militärischen Bedrohung
oder Eskalation da jetzt für den Moment
erstmal nicht sehen trotzdem ist die
NATO und die Mitgliedstaaten sind ja
immer wieder darum bemüht vor allem die
Ostflanke der NATO zu schützen auch und
ein erklärtes Ziel der Bundesregierung
natürlich jetzt hat Boris Pistorius war
in den vergangenen Tagen in Litauen und
hat verkündet dass spätestens ab
2027 bis zu 5000 deutsche Soldatinnen
und Soldaten dort dauerhaft stationiert
werden sollen wir haben dazu auch eine
Frage bekommen bei Youtube von IE der
fragt uns nämlich müsste die NATO
müssten mehr natooalitionstruppen in
Finnland stationiert werden also um die
Ostflanke und auch Finnland besser durch
eine russische Bedrohung zu
schützen also derjenige der für ganz
vereinfacht gesagt den operativen
die operative Planung der
Verteidigungsmaßnahmen der NATO
zuständig ist ist sakur also der
Oberbefehlshaber der alliierten Truppen
in Europa der amerikanische general
kavoli und der hat ein riesengroßes Team
und die sitzen ja nun schon seit Z
Jahren da dran um zu schauen wie sie
Truppen natoruppen möglichst schnell
möglichst interoperabel
an bestimmte
Konfliktpunkte innerhalb des
Territoriums kriegen können wie sie die
dorthins schicken können wie sie ihre
Übungen gestalten können und jetzt
speziell was Finnland angeht ist das
Teil der Verhandlung zwischen wenn Sie
so wollen dem sakur dem General kavolli
und seinen Planung seinen Überlegung der
wird sagen was brauchen wir
schlussendlich für vielleicht permanente
Stationierung in in Finnland was möchte
die Regierung das ist ja ein
Verhandlungsprozess das ist nichts was
letztendlich die NATO einem Mitglied
diktieren kann aber grundsätzlich wird
es darum gehen wie sich der NATO
Footprint also der Fußabdruck ganz
konkret in Finland darstellt und da
werden wir noch am Anfang sein wir sind
noch nicht da und haben sozusagen alle
Teile glaube ich schon parat aber der
erste Schritt ist der den ich schon
genannt hat nämlich den
das Sicherheitsabkommen zwischen
Finnland und den USA wenn es da darum
geht letztendlich auch amerikanische
Truppenpräsenz in Finnland
festzulegen und natürlich auch rechtlich
im Rahmen eines eines Abkommens zu
untermauern Frau Babs abschließend
vielleicht noch an Sie die Frage jetzt
haben wir die Drohung von Putin vom
Wochenende gehört ist das möglicherweise
der Auftakt zu weiteren Drohung oder
muskelspielchen die wir von Putin
gegenüber natostaaten erleben werden wir
erleben Sie seit mittlerweile fast zi
Jahren in periodischen Abständen
wir reagieren auf westlicher Seite
eigentlich immer gleich darauf wir
halten uns denn am Ende des Tages
deutlich bedeckt weil es eben keinen
politischen Konsens innerhalb der
Verbündeten gibt Präsident Putin
wirklich konkrete strategisch deutliche
rote Linien aufzuzeigen und wir haben
jetzt einen Präsidenten der in den
sogenannten Wahlkampf geht das muss man
natürlich mit anführungs stricheln äh
sagen weil das ja kein demokratischer
Wahlkampf ist aber natürlich wird ihn
das ermuntern noch mehr und deutlicher
also seine Ansprüche zu artikulieren
Drohungen auszustoßen gegenüber dem
Westen von dem er ja sagt dass wir
letztendlich äh nicht nur dekadente und
und völlig unfähige Gesellschaften sind
sondern wir sind die Bedrohung die
unmittelbare Bedrohung russischer
Sicherheit und das sind wir seit 24
Monaten und das lebt er in seiner
militärischen Zerstörungswut in der
Ukraine aus also schlussendlich ja wir
werden mehr davon hören und wir werden
so lange von Präsident Putin diese
wilden Behauptung hören wie wir es ihm
gestatten